[Music]
[Narrator:] The typical chancre is raised,
indurated, sharply circumscribed,
frequently ulcerated, usually has satellite buboes,
and is not particularly painful unless there is secondary infection.
Chancres frequently are not typical and may be multiple. Suspect any genital lesion.
In every case of urethral discharge, palpate the urethra for possible intra-urethral chancre.
Follow every case of gonorrhea with blood tests for four months to rule out syphilis.
Look for cervical chancre. Some are atypical,
consisting merely of diffuse enlargement and induration of the entire cervix.
Extragenital chancres occur on the lip,
tonsil, breast, and elsewhere.
Do darkfields on suspicion, and blood tests routinely.
Look for chancre of the finger in doctors and nurses.
They are painful and often not as typical as this one.
They frequently resemble an ordinary paronychia.
This lesion and those following are not syphilitic.
Darkfield examinations should be performed
on every genital lesion and on all suspected extragenital lesions.
If repeated darkfields are negative,
follow with blood tests for four months to rule out syphilis.
Take a blood test at least once a week for the first two months, and once a month for the next two months.
Differential diagnosis of primary syphilis
depends largely upon darkfield examination.
To prepare the lesion for obtaining a specimen,
soak a piece of gauze in normal saline solution and rub hard to produce slight abrasion.
After the surface of the lesion has been cleansed and abraded, blot it with a dry piece of gauze
and wait a few seconds for serum to ooze from the surface.
Now touch a clean, dry slide to the serum and cover specimen with a clean, dry cover slip.
The specimen is now ready to be placed under the darkfield microscope for examination.
Spirochete pallida resembles many non-pathogenic spirilla, therefore darkfield examination
should be undertaken only by one who is thoroughly experienced in this procedure.
In localities where persons experienced in
darkfield technique are not available,
the delayed darkfield technique is useful.
The specimen of serum is drawn into a capillary tube, the ends sealed, and the tube mailed immediately.
Most state health departments provide for
examination of delayed darkfield specimens.
Do not use darkfield examination for lesions inside the mouth,
unless the specimen is taken by aspiration rather than from the surface of the lesion.
Some normal mouth spirochetes cannot be distinguished from spirochete pallida.
If the lesion is on the outer surface of the lip,
cleanse the surface carefully before taking the specimen.
Specimens may also be obtained by aspiration of serum from the base of a lesion.
One tenth cc of normal saline is injected and withdrawn.
A single negative darkfield examination does not exclude syphilis.
Chancres are apt to be darkfield-negative if topical applications have been used,
if the patient has received anti-syphilitic
treatment of any kind,
or if the lesion has been present more than a month or six weeks.
At least three or four negative specimens
should be obtained
before a suspected lesion is considered darkfield-negative.
On the other hand, a positive darkfield establishes the diagnosis of syphilis
even while the blood test is still negative.
Time is of the essence in the diagnosis of syphilis.
Let us assume an exposure to syphilis or gonorrhea, or both, at this point.
In three to six days there may be evidence of gonorrhea.
Both smears and cultures should be made.
As early as ten days after exposure, the chancre may appear.
It usually develops in about 21 days,
although its appearance may be delayed as long as three months.
A darkfield examination should be employed.
A negative darkfield, of course, does not exclude syphilis.
From six to nine weeks after exposure,
the blood test may be expected to assume diagnostic significance.
Again, a single negative should not be relied upon.
The case should be followed for at least four months
before concluding that infection has not resulted from the exposure.
The control of early syphilis, and the prevention of congenital syphilis and late manifestations,
depend on careful and painstaking attention to the time element, and on a high index of suspicion.
During the secondary stage of syphilis, the
organism is disseminated throughout the body.
This gives rise to a constitutional reaction
with general malaise
and aching of the bones and joints.
Sore throat may be prominent. There is usually a generalized lymph adenopathy.
Macular syphilids are salmon or rose-colored.
If natural daylight cannot be used, the light from a blue bulb will often reveal
a macular rash which would be invisible in light from an ordinary bulb.
Involvement of the palms and soles is particularly suggestive.
Secondary syphilids are often papular.
Angular lesions should always suggest syphilis to the physician.
They frequently coalesce and assume a serpiginous appearance.
It is not uncommon for the hair to fall out
in patches, giving it a moth-eaten appearance.
Mucus patches occur in the mouth or nose or on the genitalia.
They are usually about one-half to two centimeters in diameter, sharply circumscribed,
pink, and slightly raised from the surrounding surface.
Ordinarily, they are not painful.
Moist papules also known as condyloma lata occur on moist contiguous surfaces of the skin.
They are raised from the surrounding surface and are round and flat on top.
Venereal warts are not syphilitic lesions.
They differ from moist papules in that they are flat on the sides rather than on top.
The split papules shown here are large, but often they are so small as to be overlooked easily.
Split papules may be the only sign
of secondary syphilis.
Darkfield examination is positive.
In cases of iritis, the physician should think first of atropine and second of a blood test.
Many cases are due to secondary syphilis.
The symptoms and signs of early meningeal neurosyphilis are those of any acute meningitis.
This condition is distinguished by the positive
spinal fluid serologic test for syphilis.
It often follows a lapse in treatment for early syphilis, and in such cases is called neuro-recurrence.
Darkfield examination is useful in secondary syphilis as well as in primary syphilis.
A diagnosis of primary or secondary syphilis should always be confirmed
either by positive darkfield or positive blood tests.
To obtain a specimen for blood test, a tourniquet is first applied to the upper arm.
If the veins are not prominent, one is located by palpation.
The overlying skin is cleansed with alcohol.
The operator's left thumb draws the skin taut,
and the needle is inserted through the skin
at an acute angle and lowered until almost
parallel with the vein.
The vein is entered and blood withdrawn.
The blood is placed in a clean, dry test tube.
The tube is stoppered with a clean, dry cork, carefully labeled and prepared for mailing.
Do not use soap to clean test tubes for this purpose.
Any residual of soap will cause hemolysis of the blood.
Congenital syphilis is transmitted from mother to fetus in utero,
usually about the fifth month of pregnancy.
Frequently the fetus dies and a miscarriage or stillbirth results.
The infant with active early congenital syphilis is fretful and often has snuffles.
Crusted lesions about the mouth and nose are frequently observed.
There may be a generalized eruption and moist papules about the anus and genitalia.
The diagnosis should be confirmed by darkfield examination of the lesions, or by blood tests, or by both.
Apparently well babies of both treated and untreated syphilitic mothers should be followed for at least two years.
Perform blood tests at monthly intervals for six months and every six months thereafter.
In the absence of other evidence, a diagnosis of syphilis should not be made on the basis
of positive blood tests taken when the child is less than two months old,
unless quantitative tests reveal a rising titer.
Congenital syphilis can be prevented by treating infected mothers,
but first the infected mothers must be found.
Take a blood test as soon as pregnancy is suspected.
Repeat at least once later in pregnancy.
Take a blood test as a routine part of physical examinations before marriage.
More than half of the cases of syphilis so discovered will have been unsuspected.
Blood tests before marriage are the particular responsibility of the private physician
to whom most couples go.
A blood test experienced impresses itself on the minds of the young people.
If it is accompanied by a physical examination, and if the full significance of the procedure
is brought home to the couple, an important
relationship is established with the physician.
Later, when pregnancy occurs, the physician is afforded the opportunity not only to meet
the threat of congenital syphilis but also
to provide general pre-natal care.
Thus the private practitioner plays a vital
and fundamental part
in both medical and epidemiologic aspects of syphilis control.
Personalized education by him vitalizes the mass program of the health department.
Every case of syphilis comes from another case.
To break this chain of infection, all contact, whether familial or non-familial,
should be examined by the physician, or for him by the health department.
Prostitution is another...link in
the chain of infection.
Physicians can help to break this link by demanding that law enforcement officers
vigorously enforce all laws prohibiting prostitution, procurement, solicitation, and assignation.
Periodic examination of prostitutes does not retard the spread of venereal diseases,
and it involves the physician as an accessory to the fact.
Nothing short of total war on vice will break
this link in the chain of infection.
To keep abreast of current developments in the diagnosis, treatment,
and public health aspects of syphilis, read Venereal Disease Information, one of the medical journals
published by the United States Public Health Service.
[Music]